foreign
is protesting at someone's precious day
their wedding taking it a step too far
to discuss this we're joined by author
and commentator Constantine kizzin and
Tracy malagan from insulate written
Constantine first what do you think I
mean you know Free Speech somebody's
right to throw orange confetti over
newlyweds is it throwing things that
people in speech are very different
things you're a politician once some
people might take issue with decisions
that you made should they turn up at
your house and throw you don't know what
they're throwing you've got to remember
this George Osborne looked as he's
walking away you can see he looks quite
concerned because the strangers walking
up to him and is about to throw
something on him and his bride I think
that that is erosion of the public
safety of politicians and by the way
we've obviously had a series of
incidents in this country and in the
United States where as you know most
politicians are having to walk around
with bodyguards now is that the society
we want to be moving to well Tracy
Mulligan you are a spokesperson for
insulate Britain you have taken part in
direct protest yourself you've sat
on the M25 couple of years ago in order
to protest now that causes aggravation
for drivers of course would you go as
far as it to interrupt someone's wedding
if I'd been asked to do that specific
action I'd have had to say I couldn't do
it because I couldn't promise that I
wouldn't have slapped him instead of
just going confetti
non-violence I'm really angry like this
man is responsible for killing what's
non-violent about slapping someone
listen what I said was I would have said
I couldn't do it because your gun
violence is so important with the
resistance that is happening you know
people are in resistance because we
don't want to revolt in Revolt and the
truth is you know I've heard you
Constantine say you know that feelings
do not matter as much as the truth and
the truth is they killed 330
000 of our most vulnerable now if any
other gang of people had done that
they'd be in prison but because their
MPS they're having more push parties
right so when was this trial sorry where
they were convicted of murder and when
did that happen it's the austerity
figures 330 so you're linking the
measures to the deaths of that many
people I'm giving you respawn himself
personally
you know what about if so I was just
playing your what about games so what
about if I personally been asked I'd
have had to say I'm too angry with that
man and non-violence is really really
important because he also laid climate
denial right you can't seriously be like
oh poor Georgie boys feelings with a bit
of confession is George Osborne lead
climate denial he was really responsible
for a lot of terrible
um media messaging that went out he said
he didn't want Britain to be leading in
it do not know that uh climate in that
really yeah honestly shock him I I know
and he looks like such a nice man I
thought David Cameron was the person
with George Osborne yeah who persuaded
the conservative party to embrace saving
the planet of the planet hugging a husky
tackling climate change was that was
that well they might have said that to
the public but what they did behind the
scenes was not that at all they were
writing climate in our ports they were
canceling projects that we needed to do
come on edge you needed a bit heavier
and tell us what happened sorry tell us
what happened what happened with what
darling what you sorry you don't need to
call me darling
um tell me what it is that you think Ed
should know
that our government MPS at the moment
are issuing kill policies right we're in
this climate crisis
take are we I was told we shouldn't talk
about Georgia yeah
George Osborne yeah everybody should
know I'm just asking yeah
he wrote and led the leading of the
writing of climate denial you know Boris
Johnson apologized speeches
can you just tell us one thing he did
you know it's like letting people like
Julia Hartley program question in time
and say where there's just sorry I said
you don't like what a battery and now
you're talking about somebody else Julie
Hartley Brewer was not going to MP when
George had no time well George Osmond
had no role all these jobs right they go
around Amanda Circle empties
lawyers we're sure just pun connected to
Julia Hartley Brewer I'm not sure where
we're going with oh who goes on question
time
okay I didn't understand that at all
okay so part of the problem that we have
you're asking how has George and me to
and other people led us into this mess
is I not having the right conversation
isn't a bigger question if you want as a
movement
um in state Britain or just up oil to
persuade people that your cause is worth
supporting you have to do things which
make people think well I support that
people don't support well that could be
the M25 they don't support I don't think
throwing things on people and they don't
support people coming on this program
and then but they've not been able to
say anything they also don't stop
wanting the changes that we need just
because they don't want to change
everything I want the I want the changes
I want to tackle clients so how are we
going to get there well
um we got there because I was part of
the government we should introduce the
first ever energy
the courts have just said that our
current targets let's talk about 1997.
you made an allegation about Georgia and
then you were unable to suspend anything
[Music]
how our media is supporting this how are
MPS are talking about we're listening
without saying what is popular well
literally don't want to just tell the
truth we're listening to you and what
you're saying tell me one thing George
Osborne did yeah set back the cause of
climate change while Chancellor you can
all Google it he said you told me
you said to me get with the program
ahead get on top of it I'm saying to you
tell me what I didn't say you did say
that you talk you challenged me that I
didn't know what I was talking about so
I'm asking you to tell me one thing
which proves you know what you're
talking about tell me one thing George
Osborne did as Chancellor to set back
climate change he didn't put it to the
top of the agenda he didn't talk about
it openly and honestly that how are you
still denying that climate denial is a
thing the the people who let it have
been who's denying the climate denial
well back all fast this world
who is that denying the climate denial
is a thing they've asked you for one
example of something George Osborne did
and you haven't killed please
wait Millions
setback climate change so what they're
doing here what is going on is aim to
have the first question do you remember
when Laura Tobin did a lovely segment
last time Liam was on he was in the seat
Laura Tobin did a segment on the science
do you remember what you said as soon as
she'd finished because it made me cry
Susanna oh I'm sorry it made you cry
what was it you don't remember Laura
Tobin giving her I'd say yes
your house insulated now that is just
all you're doing is
Britain so shoot the messenger and you
know where that phrase comes from don't
shoot the messenger why did that make
you cry because you heard
how terrible things are going to be
water shortages food shortages and you
smartly looked at them and went is your
house insulated like that yeah an
intelligent response that is shooting
the messenger your campaign is literally
to get everybody's house insulated I
just wanted to know if the spokesperson
from insulate Britain so you think
that's an intelligent question it's so
not we are so beautiful quick question
it really isn't in the past game of
things right an appropriate question
would be how are people who are poor and
enforced poverty dying in the hundreds
of thousands going to afford insulation
and should we look after each other and
work together
we're talking about no that's a legit
on the streets who are asking for this
madness to stop okay you know all right
deliber of democracy don't we not
Clarity contest do you think when you
block the M25 you advance your cause or
set it back me personally I have seen
the effect it had on the people last
time I was coming on here I didn't even
tell my mum what was the answer to the
question does it Advance the cause or
set it back a little bit of orange
confetti and the whirlpool things
when you block the M25 do you advance
the cause of tackling climate change or
do you set it yeah because people don't
want to cut off their notes and I didn't
hear about them answer any questions at
all can you give me a few minutes to
answer it go on so I hadn't heard that
there was a climate crisis until there
was protest right many of us out there
do not know because we trust that our me
to our government if things were this
bad they would let us know but it's only
because I'm disabled that I've had loads
of hours to watch select committees read
really really boring dull reports that I
know what was going on and that breaks
my heart you show all the time people
who hate what we're doing on the streets
but I know because I've been on them
there are loads of people who come up to
us and say thank God because I feel like
I'm going mad what conversation are we
having around them okay the problem is
that Laura Tobin who you mentioned a
moment ago advances the cause of
tactical climate change which comes on
our program and I'm afraid your protests
and the way you are answering questions
today sets back the course
insulated like that's you know the wit
of the world
why is that I still don't understand why
it's you don't understand why that made
me cry you don't understand why you
hearing about us facing our children
facing drought famine and War and your
response being is your house in selectly
and broke my heart Susanna right so let
him ask a question yes Tracy just I'm
curious what percentage if you could
tell that people are born what
percentage of global climate emissions
is Britain responsible okay for every
country what percentage it's a figure
every country I'll tell you it's
responsible about two percent
I'm trying if we
do what you want which is spend 1.5
trillion pounds which is about eight
years worth of the NHS
Net Zero if we do that by what
percentage will we reduce global
temperatures about which you're so your
argument is silly answer the question
what impact not telling people what they
want to hear leading is doing the right
thing regardless of what anybody else
are doing and China actually a way ahead
if we reduce I'm gonna say that that's
the first thing you've said today I
agree so if we do that okay for a bit
longer what result will be extremely
uncomfortable you've got to tell the
people of Britain if you want to spend
one point
if you were to spend 1.5 trillion pounds
of British taxpayers money what result
would you achieve I think people would
like to know that what we need is
deliberative democracy we need
participate we budgeting we need people
so you don't know we need you don't know
I know local temperatures and we all
need to take responsibility okay all
right all right
okay good okay this is going to make you
happy
because we've got Laura Tobin we do love
Laura on the program I think he's
incredible she won't make you cry
ing Constantine kissing Laura take it
away
good morning well as you both said and
as the viewers know communication